We expect of course for it to be the other
way around. We teaching him but he has a host
of important lessons for us too, if we take
care to listen.
It's easy to play it tough
nowadays, to overdo independence but to have
survived we all needed as he does an extraordinary
amount of care from those around us. He is
a reminder that no-one makes themselves and
therefore that we're heavily in someone usually
under acknowledged debt and should perhaps
call, our mother.
As adults we give love chiefly
because of what others can do for us, but
he doesn't deserve much of anything. He can't
do a thing for anyone. He cries too much and
is asleep most of the time yet we devote ourselves
to him nevertheless. So he teaches us about
the truest, purest kind of love. Which means
giving affection without expecting anything
in return simply because someone needs help
and one happens to be in a position to give it.
He can't of course, tell us what is wrong
with him. We have to guess; but what's striking
is how generous we are in interpreting what
could be at stake. When he cries we don't
accuse him of being mean. When he hits or
kicks we assume he must be frightened or momentarily
vexed. We are constantly aware it might just
be hunger, a tricky digestive tract or a lack
of sleep. How kind we would be if we could
be similarly imaginative around adults.
If we could look beneath their surface behaviour,
the unpleasantness, viciousness and grumpiness...
and can trust that here too it was probably also
just fear, pain or exhaustion.
It's easy to get sickened by our species,
the greed, the status consciousness, the vanity, we should
hang out with him as a corrective. He doesn't
care what you do or how much you're making.
He cares about laughter, friendship, people
who are nice to him. We were all like this once.
It's society that corrupted us and encouraged
our unhealthier impulses. He's a political
philosopher, he pointing to how we might all
be if only the world would be
newly and better arranged.